[Musique]
il nous reçoit chez lui en musique au
coeur même de son intimité puisque son
atelier a pris place au beau milieu du
salon familial des bandes de couleurs
par dizaines et des toiles récentes dont
l'exposition au théâtre il a travaillé
sans relâche des jours et surtout des
nuits entre euphorie et inquiétude il
espère s'être renouvelée c'est toi là
qu'est ce qu'elle dit de toi ce qu'elle
dit de moi là c'est que elle va être au
théâtre et les traiter comme une
improvisation théâtrale et violente où
elle plutôt joyeuse c'est une très bonne
question j'espère qu'elle est les deux
le regard c'est la force de cieux il
peut passer des heures en moins de
contemplatif à scruter sa toile avant
d'y mettre sa patte
une couleur un pigment le geste est
précis ou non il adore les grands
classiques et cela se voit molière
shakespeare tchekhov son préféré
pour moi c'est c'est nina c'est nina
dans l'acte de même parce que je trouve
qu'elle revient plus forte qu'elle est
moins jeunes premières clés qu'elle a
gagné en maturité et en force
j'espère que ça soit dans le regard ce
qui m'a un tout petit peu éloigné du
théâtre c'est la passivité de l'exercice
c'est d'attendre que son téléphone sonne
c'est de dépendre du casting de tout ça
et j'ai alors je lui en veux pas mais la
peinture c'est plus direct
la peinture c'est un résultat tout de
suite on va à notre cadence et le
phénomène de création ne passe pas par
un intermédiaire écrit où il est direct
il est fulgurant et et oui c'est en ça
que la peinture me rend heureux
les mots le théâtre la vie la mort cieux
c'est un peu tout cela à la fois son
travail ne laisse jamais indifférent
il est exposé au théâtre pendant un mois